hey guys here we are at CES 2015 I'm
Justin this is Peter and we just got
done seeing some really cool stuff from
oculus it's not entirely new they have a
new crescent bulb they have the Crescent
Bay device here which we saw it oculus
connect early last year but they've
added some new things to this one and
you didn't get to try it last year and
they've added some 3d virtual audio but
with the with the new introductions to
to the hardware so what do you think
about the experience now you've gone
through a lot of iterations of the 3d
yeah i've been using oculus rift since
the first demo when it was really like
well resolution like nothing was really
right they've come a really long way and
even though that not much has changed on
paper since the demo that you did at
oculus connects they've added now 3d
audio and as partner lucky always says
one of the creators of the oculus
actually be creator everything you do is
sort of like a house of cards are you
need every little thing to fall into
place so the 3d audio really does sort
of continue to build that house of cards
and that immersion so now when you move
in space you know if there's fire
crackling over here your orientation
really just sort of you know it tells
your brain where that is in space and
even though you're not seeing it you can
tell where that is just like in the real
world so as VR is growing things like
this make a big difference and yeah it's
just one little change but for me it did
make a large difference i thought it was
much better yeah i mean with regular
surround sound audio you're gonna hear
that all around you but the way that
they're pitching it the way that the 3d
audio works is that whether it's above
you whether it's below you you're gonna
be able to sense that you're gonna be
able to hear it and know that it's
something above you it's something below
you which is necessary for a truly
immersive 3d experience yeah and we've
seen a lot of different kinds of VR here
at the show but I mean honestly oculus
is the one that that always really
convinces me that there's a future for
via for virtual reality yeah and I think
one of the more important things for
people to realize is that until you've
really tried like the latest iteration
of oculus headset you cannot grasp just
by someone and explaining it to you how
good it is one of the devil is that they
had with this 3d audio it ran you
through a bunch of different scenarios
and you're on this sort of like a raised
platform then they cut to this demo
where you're on the top of a building in
the middle
and you're essentially like a foot away
from the edge and they're like okay take
it step out and you can feel the edge of
this platform on the bottom of your foot
and as you lean over this the sound of
the city feels as though it's in the
proper space you feel that relationship
to being so far up you get a realistic
sense of vertigo of looking down for 30
40 stories yeah one of our colleagues
one of our camera people would not take
the step off the lead because she was so
convinced that it not that it was
reality but that you know her sort of
flight or flight response kicked in and
she couldn't do it I took with this step
and it was invigorating and like the
worst but coolest way possible because
it kind of proves like how effective
these things are and I guess how viable
I know oculus is among all the VR
headsets and it looks like we're getting
a lot closer to a consumer model but we
don't know when this is going to come
out we still don't have a firm date and
we still don't know how input is going
to work for a system like this the
oculus is definitely still working on
input but when it comes to the head said
they basically said the feature set they
have right now is essentially solidified
so when the consumer version comes
you're going to expect basically the
same thing we've experienced at the show
so even though we don't know when this
consumer version is coming out we do
have the samsung gear vr which is
showing us a brief glimpse of the some
of the future and that's available right
now and one really cool thing that we
saw was kind of like a not an
interactive trailer but sitting in for
wild reese witherspoon in style starring
in a movie called wild coming out later
this year and you get to see kind of a
scene that was made for for the movie
and you're sitting in it and it's a very
immersive way to to experience a trailer
that we really haven't seen before yeah
I was a companion piece of a shop of the
360 degree camera so you can look all
around you and experience the entire
scene starts off with her narrating she
walks up to you sits on a log you're
focused on her until she looks towards
you and you realize that way why is she
looking at me you turn around or maybe
you've already looked and there sits her
mother and it's just this use of
misdirection and it's again it's all
those little elements coming together to
convince you that you're a part of the
scene
you want to look at her and then you
sort of led to like see this other thing
in it it you know this direction is the
thing that's using games in the film i
guessing games more effectively but this
was a really interesting way to
experience that a film and to see that
kind of come to life on a phone with the
3d audio coming out of that on the
headset I mean for two hundred dollars
you can get that from Samsung right now
and you can experience these sort of
things I just think that's great so VR
is really starting to kick itself in a
high gear if companies like razor who
are offering open source stuff to
continue the movement get in more
developers hands exciting times are
ahead for sure and that's the exciting
thing about CES this year it's
incremental upgrades to be are nothing
really really big but it's really
exciting to see where it's going